so nächster reden ist an nigel farage
der wahlsieger der europawahlen in
großbritannien mit seinem break party
der sich diesmal entschlossen hat nicht
einer fraktion sich anzuschließen mit
seinen rund 30 abgeordneten anschließend
dann hat ursula von der leyen zum ersten
mal die möglichkeit auf all die wildnis
zu antworten und ich komme zurück jetzt
da wir zu einem ort hoch der genehmigung
der alte taste europäische rat jetzt
keine schuld hat dazu geführt dass das
parlament auch ohnmächtig ist bis heute
nun wenn sie möchten können sie ihre
können etwas tun aber das fast jetzt ja
getan wird mit der kandidaten oder von
frau von der leyen
das ist der versuch wird die kontrolle
zu ergreifen über jeden bereich unseres
lebens sehen möchte hier eine
zentralisierte undemokratische
aktualisierter form des kommunismus
schaffen wodurch die parlamente in den
nationalstaaten 100 signal starke
parlamente überhaupt keine bedeutung
haben werden
von unserem standpunkt aus muss ich
folgendes sagen ich bin auf eine gewisse
art und weise erfreut denn dadurch ist
jetzt wesentlich populärer geworden im
vereinten königreich gott sei dank dass
wir ausscheiden
aber was die verteidigungs aspekte
angibt darauf sollten wir uns
konzentrieren
wir sind eine fanatikerin sie möchte
eine europäische armee haben aber sie
stehen nicht allein dort werden das
vollendet ist das nato nicht mehr
existieren oder wird zumindest in europa
keine bedeutung haben und der
französische staatspräsident mächte
natürlich auch nicht außen vor bleiben
deshalb hat er am letzten sonntag oben
auf einem offenen wagen gestanden hatte
seine europäische verteidigung ist der
kraft hinter sich und hat in der ganzen
welt so dagestanden als ob er eine neue
form von napoleon wäre
wir sollten keinen zweifel hegen fünf
jahre mit derartige menschen das würde
bedeuten dass die europäische
verteidigung union vollendet würde und
die verteidigung kann auch für einen
angriff genutzt werden und sie als
parlament werden überhaupt keine
kontrolle darüber haben sie sollte nicht
gegen diese kandidatin stimme sie
sollten wirklich für die demokratie
eintreten
sie sollten für ihre bürger eintreten
[Applaus]